completely digital expansive unique
worlds spacecraft and creatures are now
pretty commonplace in blockbuster films
and even tv what's possible with visual
effects is incredibly impressive yeah
when i watch dune there's a very unique
quality to the way denis villeneux
builds and portrays his world on screen
what makes the visuals of dune stand
apart and feel different from almost
everything else i want to say up front
that while i'm a big fan of the grounded
realistic way that villeneuve puts his
visual effects on screen
i'm not saying that his approach is
inherently better than any of the others
i'm going to be comparing it to instead
what i want to try to showcase here is
how very small differences can add up to
change how we perceive the end product
on screen this video is sponsored by
mubi
look for example at this scene from
mcu's recent black widow this entire
sequence has pretty extensive green
screen work and one of the dead
giveaways is that the lighting on
natasha's face always remains fairly
flat and even and perfect regardless of
what's going on in the scene right here
natasha's face remains perfectly evenly
lit even while there's a huge explosion
going on behind her the uniformity of
this exposure actually kind of defies
the physics of what would be possible
with a camera and so it just naturally
has a sort of feeling of artifice to our
eyes compare the light on her face from
those moments with the light on her face
from these moments which appear to be
shot in an actual practical environment
see how the lighting on her face is
imperfect and actually has tiny shadows
that change
now check out this moment from dune the
explosion behind the characters throws
all of the characters into silhouette
this is what would happen naturally if
you actually tried to shoot this kind of
scene in real life the camera literally
wouldn't be able to properly expose both
the characters and the explosion behind
them while shooting the scene in dune
while they didn't have a practical
explosion behind the characters they
still created a real punch of light
behind them this ensured that the
lighting on the characters matched the
action of the scene both of these shots
use computer generated imagery my point
here is not that cgi or digital
compositing is bad the difference is how
the shots are lit and the one style of
lighting really grounds it within
reality and the other has a slightly
more comic cartoonish effect hawking and
sabotage slows us down one of the key
decisions in dune was to shoot
everything that takes place outside
actually outside in natural lighting or
sunlight this made shooting on certain
sets more difficult because they'd have
to construct a massive set and yet
somehow still protect it from the
elements and let in enough light to
shoot what they needed to this also
limited when they could shoot because
they'd have to wait for the sun to be in
the correct position but the intensity
and contrast provided by real sunlight
is incredibly difficult to produce in a
studio at such large scale a great
example of this is this scene
villeneuves and frasier's lighting in
dune is much more expressive and
contrasty than we're used to from these
kinds of films i'll touch more on
lighting later but there are a lot of
little subtle details like this that can
ground an artificial image in a sense of
reality
in dune sand and wind blowing everywhere
is another one that's frequently used in
these scenes even though everything
surrounding and behind the characters is
a digital set extension the sand and
wind blowing the characters is very real
the production actually used 18 tons of
sand and dust in the course of making
the film of course not all the sand
blowing in the wind in the whole film is
real a lot of it still had to be added
or enhanced in post but for vfx
supervisor paul lambert the holy grail
of visual effects is using them to
extend or enhance reality instead of
creating it completely from scratch so
even when they were using entirely
digital ornithopters they still went out
and shot footage of helicopters landing
and actually blowing sand around in the
wind sometimes they would just replace
the helicopter digitally with the
ornithopter and sometimes they would
just use that image of the sand blowing
in the wind for reference and recreate
it entirely somewhere else so it's not
that cgi is not capable of creating
realistic looking wind and sand it's
just that making it look super realistic
is a lot easier to do when you have
actual footage to reference another
great example of creating a small
practical effect and then expanding that
digitally is this sand displacement
effect that's used as worms are
approaching this was created practically
by placing a metal plate under the sand
that vibrated that effect can be then
expanded and enhanced digitally but it's
going to look realistic because the vfx
artists are going to be forced to match
what they're adding to the real effect
that was shot practically
often when shooting through windows into
vehicles like this crews will remove the
glass from the vehicle so that the shot
is cleaner and also so that they're not
dealing with reflections from the green
screen or blue screens then they add
back reflections and glass in
post-production but for dune these
scenes were shot with the windows
installed something they could actually
do because they didn't have to worry
about green or blue spill because they
were using the sand screens and then the
subtle but natural reflections that they
got from the sand screen in the windows
were enhanced using high resolution
footage of actual desert that they shot
with helicopters
one of the issues with surrounding your
characters or your set with a huge green
or blue screen is in a real environment
there's subtle lights that reflect and
bounce off of the objects that surround
the characters in the scene for example
right now my monitor right here is
reflecting a certain amount of light
onto my face and if i turn it off you'll
be able to notice the difference if i
hold a piece of paper near my face you
can easily see how much light is being
reflected onto my face by the paper so
when you surround a character by blue
screen or green screen you lose all of
those subtle natural reflections and
bounces that you would get off of a real
environment this is one of the distinct
advantages of the new wraparound led
system that's being developed and used
extensively on shows like the
mandalorian by surrounding a character
with a digital screen you actually get
light from that environment reflecting
and bouncing onto the characters greg
frazier the cinematographer for dune
also shot the first season of the
mandalorian and so he tested out those
led screens to see if it might be an
option for dune unfortunately led
screens aren't bright enough to create
the kind of high contrast sunlight blast
of light that would be in the kinds of
environments that they're creating for
dune so frazier villeneuve and vfx
supervisor paul lambert would have to
come up with a different solution if
they wanted to avoid using green screen
or blue screen the idea lambert
eventually came up with was to use sand
colored screens instead of blue or green
blue and green screens are usually used
because those are the easiest colors to
separate from the foreground but sand
colored screens were still close enough
and uniform enough that they could get
the job done and they had the added
benefit of casting a sand colored bounce
into the scenes for example when they
shot the scenes in the ornithopter they
surrounded them with these sand screens
instead of green screens and then the
light bouncing into the vehicles was the
appropriate color light reflecting from
the environment is an incredibly subtle
detail one that you won't really notice
unless you stop and really examine a
shot but it's these small details that
when you sacrifice them eliminate
elements of reality and lend a digital
composite a feeling of artifice
lighting isn't the only way visual
effects can defy physical reality when
you're shooting a scene that's
constructed entirely out of cgi are
mostly out of cgi you can create virtual
cameras that can move around in space
however you want you can see some good
examples of this in the snyder cut the
camera here is doing moves that would be
totally physically impossible or
extremely difficult if you were doing
them with an actual physical camera but
a digital camera can fly and twist
however you want and do it perfectly
smoothly again keep in mind i'm not
saying these kinds of shots aren't cool
or should never be used but by defying
physical possibility they remove a sense
of realism which is bad if realism is
your goal dune absolutely uses digital
cameras for certain shots so digital
cameras themselves aren't the issue here
but you're just not going to find these
kinds of physics-defying camera
movements in dune the creative team
intentionally avoided any kind of camera
movements that weren't grounded in
reality so in a scene like this you
could have the camera diving and
swooping with the ornithopter but the
camera stays fairly constrained and
moves in the broader more linear
movements that could actually be
accomplished with a helicopter if you
were filming this practically
in general as well the cinematography in
dune is just fairly constrained if dune
were made in the way that many modern
blockbuster films are it would be easy
to imagine a shot at this moment that
goes sweeping past the minor across the
dunes and towards the approaching worm
but villeneuve instead stays with the
characters i think this approach to
cinematography in general is also part
of what just helps everything feel more
grounded villeneuve is very careful with
his cinematography to pay close
attention to the relationship between
characters and objects in the world his
visual effects often include people for
scale or reference or are from the
perspective of characters in the scene
overall i think villeneuve's approach to
visual effects is actually quite
constrained you don't really get the
feeling that he's using the camera to
just show off the visual effects in many
moments you have really cool costume
design visual effects or ships and
they're just being almost completely
obscured by dust or smoke because that's
what would happen realistically if a
bunch of ships with whirly wings landed
in a completely sandy dusty environment
or in this moment you can't really make
out the benny jesuit ship because the
lights on the ship blow the image
completely into black in a sense you
have to sacrifice clarity of the visuals
and sometimes getting to see the coolest
element of the shot to create a shot
that looks like it would if you were
actually trying to shoot this thing in
reality
cgi has reached the stage where it can
create very realistic 3d objects but
creating visuals that feel grounded has
less to do with the creation of those
objects and more to do with the details
of the world that surround those objects
the lighting of the scene reflection on
windows blowing sand and dust and camera
movement are all details that frame and
contextualize the visual effects and
help them look real even with entirely
digital creations like the worm based on
interviews the aspect of the worm that
the vfx team was most nervous about
getting right was the movement of sand
around the worm
this grounded style isn't inherently
better than more stylized approaches to
visual effects but in an industry where
visual excess is a defining
characteristic of many blockbusters i
find this more minimalistic grounded
approach very refreshing and unique
and dune shows us that with care and
creativity and how you apply its use
extensive digital imagery is not
antithetical to realism in film
denis villeneuve did not start out
making massive big budget films with
tons of visual effects if you want to
see the trajectory of his career i
recommend you check out his first film
august 32nd on earth which you can watch
right now in the us on mubi a hand
curated library of international art
house indie classic films it's a great
place to discover movies you're going to
fall in love with and get access to
films that you would never find anywhere
else right now they're featuring some of
danny vale news earlier work and i
definitely recommend checking that out
you can sign up for a 30-day extended
free trial at mubi.com thomasflight
every movie is chosen by a human because
they think it's worth your time they
even offer a little explanation of why
it might be worth checking out movie's
the only streaming service where i
actually go on to try to find new films
that i think i'll be interested in
watching so if you want to expand the
cinema you're watching there's no excuse
not to give it a try click the link
below or go to movie.com
thomasflight
[Music]
you